[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling how you do
it it is the lef koe man adam lefko
and i need to get ready for the nfl
draft because i'm gonna be hosting it
with this guy to my left connor rogers
he's been focused on it for a year i've
been an nba on tnt
nba land and i need to learn so before i
kind of give a breakdown of the show
connor with your beautiful brick wall
and your perfectly quafted hair
uh man how deep in the draft are you
right now just give everybody a taste
how many players do you got like written
down and stuff how deep are you
deep left go i mean over 300 players i'm
not gonna say i know everything about
all of them but the dock is flourishing
right now
i really started about two to three
weeks after we finished last year's trap
together when we were all kind of
sitting around like this doing it from
home so
i'm excited man a draft highlighted by
quarterbacks and skill
talent and some blue chip players that
we're gonna talk about today
i can't wait to catch you up so we're
gonna be uh cramming for nfl draft
weekend
at the end of april we're gonna be doing
this for eight weeks at one o'clock
live three different places the br app
which i have on my phone right now and
i'm looking at all your ridiculous
comments
uh br's youtube channel and of course
gridiron twitter so shout out to
everybody on all of those platforms
uh if you are listening to this after
the fact on the left go show podcast
shout out to rod simba the regulators in
rodrigo for the intro music
a note to everybody the only comments
that we're putting on the screen
and that i'm reading are on the br app
that's just how it is
so they it's like twitch you got to be a
subscriber br app is the comments that
get read
uh connor this one just came in big
philly 2020 that dude's hair is eight
feet tall
uh connor rogers fan oh my god the hair
is back
they love it okay i'm getting i'm
getting intimidated i'm getting a
haircut on saturday
just because of this okay connor you're
the one
on tv man but but we love the people
that are watching in the app
youtube gridiron or wherever you are the
draft fans of br
are the best they are loyal and we're
glad to be back a little earlier this
year than usual
uh we are going to have great guests
every week
this week we are going to have four-time
pro bowler two-time all-pro
first round pick out of lsu holding down
the left side of any offensive line you
need
andrew whitworth will be joining us get
his perspective on some of the o-line
players i know he's been watching his
tigers jamar chase
get a glimpse into that and each week
we're going to do a different theme
this week it's the question i asked to
conor every year
how many blue chippers are in this how
many guys
that will be on a franchise and will
feel like they're changing it we're
talking like jj watts and aaron donalds
and
randy mosses how many of those guys and
listen those are the top of the top
if you have any questions though they
can be about anything it doesn't just
have to be about this theme
connor my other big question for you
though is this is a year unlike any
other
so let's zoom out to 30 000 feet last
year
they got the combine done they got a
bunch of the pro days done
and then we had the kovid shut down so a
lot of the information was already
gathered
from front offices you've talked to
around the league
how different is this year the fact that
we don't even have a combine
and what is being impacted the most
it's really difficult left go you got to
realize with last year
there were some pro days already done
there was a combine already done where
every team doctor i remember getting
back getting off the plane
and it felt like within the week the
shutdown began
so it was really just done in time where
every team doctor got to do medicals
teams got to sit in the same
room and get to know these players and
even though everybody you know was upset
that oh some pro days are canceled and
private workouts are canceled
this year there is no in-person combine
they're not
every meeting with players is on zoom
every team doctor is not getting to do
their medical examination on all these
players there's going to be
pretty much universally done across the
league of course by certified people
that work for the league but
it's really different and it's they're
doing their own crash course we have
free agencies starting next week and
and you have new staffs meeting other
new staffs
so there's a lot going on here how much
can you trust all these 40 times that
are being posted is a big one that
everyone's talking about we're seeing
teams use gps on field speed this year
more so than ever analytics more so than
ever so
it's a different year left going we're
gonna learn who has the best
drafters and evaluators in the nfl real
quickly
and in the app imj richter makes a great
point
uh we just found out the salary cap is
dropping by about 10 million
and he was saying do you expect more
rookies to make the team
to make up for this loss in revenue so
there's even more importance put on it
as
i look at the top 10 teams picking in
this draft conor
i hear this every year when there's a
lack of communication oh the great teams
will have an advantage and the newer
uh units are going to have a harder time
in terms of scouts and front office
as you look at these 10 teams who are
the teams that have an advantage and who
have a disadvantage
with this crazy year with code well i
think when you look at an advantage you
start with the two that are on the back
end and that would be the dallas cowboys
at 10 and the denver broncos at nine
with the cowboys they have someone there
that runs their draft room and will
mcclay
that if he wanted to could have been a
gm by now but he likes living in the
dallas area likes working for the jones
family and with the jones family
and he's obviously a great talent
evaluator look at that cowboys team look
at their drafts over the years they hit
on picks
not just in the first round so the
cowboys are sitting pretty at 10.
the broncos at nine might surprise some
people but they made a big higher
at gm in the offseason and a guy in
george payton from minnesota
sure minnesota never got over the hump
but they consistently had one of the
better
one to 53-man rosters in the nfl year
after year from good drafting outside of
the first three rounds so
i think when you look at it those teams
are poised to capitalize left go and
even
sure john elway kind of gets out of the
way by moving himself upward
he got better over the years with the
drafts as we've seen with the broncos
but they still got to find their
quarterback of the future
now you talk about the teams that i
don't know if it's a disadvantage
but maybe a question mark you look at
your eagles right there there's been a
lot of turmoil a
take a look lot of turnovers 10 again
just so i can see that so
you said the eagles at six there's a lot
of turnover who else
well you look at the jacksonville
jaguars it's pretty easy for them
picking number one you take trevor
lawrence but they gotta hit on their
picks after that you have urban meyer
and trent balke working together
that's an interesting dynamic to me
obviously the jets with joe douglas a
lot of people are
feeling good after his first draft but
still question marks on the table
the falcons entirely new coaching staff
entirely a new scouting department
uh you look at the lines the same thing
new coach new scouting department
the panthers have matt rule there but
they made a new hire in scott federer
who a lot of people feel is ready for
the job so
this top 10 is filled with a mix of
experience
and new and a lot of teams that need a
roster makeover
yeah last year the the thing that felt
new was we saw like bill belichick's dog
and we saw we got like zoom calls of gms
but this year
we have no idea if there's any
uniformity to these boards
because there's not a lot of crossover
and everything seems to be hidden
uh i want to see your board though your
top ten big board
these are your favorite players in the
draft and then we are going to look at
how many you actually see as blue
chippers so here's connor's big board
everybody in the app
everyone on twitter everybody on youtube
take a look for the top five there on
the left
quarterbacks the only one penny sewell
out of oregon the offensive lineman
on the right side three wide receivers
in the top ten
heisman's uh trophy winner devonte smith
there at nine
micah parsons the lone defensive player
in connor rogers big board at number
eight
and kyle pitts down there at number 10.
connor how many of these guys do you see
as blue chippers
and can you define what a blue chipper
is in your mind
for me it's the top eight and i think
all 10 of these guys are going to be
pro bowlers you know all pro potential
because i know we're getting away from
the pro bowl mattering anymore
but for me it's the top eight here left
go and how i'll break that down to you
is and the thing that probably hurts a
guy like kyle pitts just a little bit
because he is special
is positional value and are you going to
be a franchise altering player
potentially
all on your own in a sense and that's
why quarterbacks you see them get that
nice little bump there
four of those eight r quarterbacks they
can change a franchise
when you look at penne sewell he's
somebody at your left tackle position
he could be a cornerstone for the next
15 years jamar chase
the strength jalen waddle the speed
special
special attributes left go micah parsons
the only defender on the list
if you look at these players they could
be the top of their position
that's what makes them a blue chip
player not top of the position or
a good starter for their team i'm
talking about a special cornerstone in
the nfl when you see all those
ridiculous
lists come out these guys can be some of
the highlights of those
lists garrett greenlee commenting
where is rashawn slater don't worry we
are gonna break him down shortly he's
right there on the cusp but he's not in
connor's top 10. and i'm going to need
you to explain kyle pitts in a second
but first we do have an
app comment here and it is asking if we
put
all of the 10 guys into a royal rumble
which prospect would win i'm going to
just say this really quick
our producer when we were going over
this uh before the show
said that in royal rumbles they always
gang up on the big guy
so connor we're throwing penny sewell
out they all team up and they throw them
over the top ropes
if you take him out who do you see
winning the royal rumble of the top ten
i'm probably gonna roll with somebody
like micah parsons and it's gonna be a
bloodbath between him and kyle pitts i
think it's a shame that they're all
bullied penne sewell and
that never happened to him once in
college but when you look at micah
parsons left go
at 6-3 you know gonna play around 250
and he runs a sub four or five so you're
talking about the
uh the elite athlete right and what
players
in a first pin wins match
i'm gonna go pen a sewell and i know a
lot of people think the low man will win
in rashaan slater but i think penne
sewell has that
reach to honestly get the upper hand in
that one
the name that i am seeing in the
comments the most
stevie97 saying kyle pitts from from day
one will be the best tight end
everybody loves kyle pitts and in the
nfl right now where i'm seeing more
double tight end sets than ever
you know could this be a premium you
don't have him as a blue chipper
i kind of want to know though where do
you see his ceiling who does he remind
you of
he reminds me of darren waller all the
way you talk about a freakish catch
radius obviously the ability to run by
any linebacker
to be bigger than any defensive back
kyle pitts is a special player now the
reason and maybe we're just getting too
carried away with the definition of blue
chip
is he's not a complete player yet i
think the competition level
or at least the effort level as a
blocker is good
and significantly improved in 2020
compared to 2019
but it's still not good it's not a trait
that you get excited about what you're
asking him to do
is this win down the field and make big
catches be an
offensive weapon like a wide receiver so
is he on that level where
you have guys like rob gronkowski and
travis kelsey that are just perfect
two-way players
he's not there yet can he get there
absolutely the size is there the effort
is there
and i do agree with that commenter from
day one
and we don't ever say this about tight
end look at all the guys over the years
with those expectations oj howard tj
hawkinson
they don't come in and produce right
away i think pitts can be the outlier
that is
very productive as soon as he steps on
an nfl field
so in my mind the best landing spot
would be for a team that already has a
blocking tight end or
one that kind of puts that tight end in
motion and would utilize it well
let's say he is a top ten pick who are
the teams that you'd be excited for his
future if he landed on
well i think when you look at atlanta or
you start with atlanta there's no reason
he can't go to them at four and that
wouldn't surprise me now i think atlanta
wants to solidify themselves on the
defensive side of the ball maybe collect
more picks
but if you put him in the middle of the
field with all that attention those
great wide receivers get on the outside
of the field
and you have an established veteran like
matt ryan i think the numbers would be
phenomenal and even if you put your best
safety or best linebacker on them
i don't think it would matter and the
same could be said for the dallas
cowboys i know everybody wants them
to really beef up their offensive line
or get insurance there for the future or
take the best cornerback
i understand that completely but just
having fun here look at this guy
after scoring that touchdown him playing
on the inside you have amari cooper cd
lamb
michael gallup a good run game i think
dak prescott would be pretty happy he
stayed there and even one more left go
if you want to talk about target share
where he can flourish and just
get 10 11 targets a game from day one i
think your eagles would be willing to
give him that
i was going to say i didn't think about
this earlier but they already have
dallas goddard who's the really good
blocker
and we know that they're going to want
run some double tight end sets so that
is interesting to me
uh we do have another app comment and
i'm
other than thanos115 who says i'm not
gonna trust a single word that lefko
says which
love you thanos you're the best uh we
have another one about trevor lawrence
um i i saw one earlier that was are you
going to talk about trevor lawrence i
think he's pretty good that was great
another comment though is is trevor
lawrence a lock
uh for the first pick in the draft do
you believe he has a lock
connor rogers the the lock of all locks
it's not even fun anymore even
the the sports books are over it they're
jacking up the odds where it makes no
sense
uh he is a lock for the number one
overall pick and he's almost so good
that we don't even really discuss him
that much anymore um
let's do that trevor lawrence let's look
at where your
ppc so i'll tell you what and a lot of
people overreacted to this when i did
the throwback one with john elway but
the more realistic one of josh allen
he is what josh allen has developed into
and what i mean by that coming out of
wyoming josh allen was a little
inaccurate
he had his question marks with decision
making but we knew he could throw it a
mile
big body really good runner and can run
through you look at trevor lawrence here
the accuracy it might be my only
question mark with him it's not perfect
it's really good but you look at him as
a runner
rpos get him on the outside he's hard to
tackle
he loves running through contact he can
scramble and keep his eyes downfield to
extend the play
he's a great leader i mean everything's
there lefko for him to be a franchise
quarterback from the second he gets to
the nfl
this is a very real talk question are
you worried about the fact
that jacksonville might be too much for
him though
listen i i think if he's level-headed
enough
and that he can overcome some of the
problems quarterbacks
have faced there and even the question
marks we have about urban meyer
transitioning to the nfl and there are
plenty
i think trevor lawrence ran a college
system right
and i think urban meyer is a guy that
understands how to adapt
those college principles to the nfl game
which we've seen become more popular
over the years where
the transition should be a little easier
for him i think they are going to try to
develop him a run game you've already
seen them
use the franchise to hang on cam
robinson which is a questionable move
but at least they're trying to keep some
offensive linemen intact
rather than letting it all go and
creating a bad situation for a rookie so
is it the perfect landing spot for a
rookie quarterback
no but for a blue chip player he can
overcome some of the problems they'll
have
early on in his career because at least
i know with the jets at number two
makai bechten is going to be there for
the next 10 years to provide
some sort of pocket you have trevor
lawrence
ahead of zack wilson you have zach
wilson as your number two
uh as a jets fan does this excite you as
someone that knows this organization
well is this the kind of guy
that you would want to build a franchise
around yeah how can it not you watch
zach wilson play and and i'll tell you
right now
he had the best ball placement out of
anyone
in 2020 and it's the incompletions
honestly that impressed me he's not
throwing to
the amari rogers of the world or the
chris alabes of the world
so you look at zach wilson i just think
how compact the mechanics are and how
easily the ball gets out
and how nimble he is in and out of the
pocket and even willing
to make a move in the open field you see
the athleticism you see the biggest guy
in the world
absolutely not i think he's a little bit
bigger version of russell wilson that's
what he reminds me of because of those
compact mechanics because of the
vertical passing game
zach wilson is an exciting prospect let
go he's not pat mahomes or the mormon
mahomes or he's not aaron rodgers
that's not who he is i think he's not
that gunslinger necessarily but in terms
of
having a great arm everything seamlessly
comes together in his mechanics and the
mobility
and honestly taking care of the football
it's all there
it all came together this year for him
and byu
by the way i looked this up last night
zach wilson's middle name
is capono which is hawaiian for
righteous i learned that i wanted to
share it with all of you guys
uh zack wilson on the jets at number two
is that a great landing spot a good
landing spot
does it make sense well they're gonna
have some work to do in free agency to
get more talent around him there's no
doubt about that the jet we saw what
happened with sam darnold
the offensive talent is lacking
firepower but in in terms of the
coaching fit
and the new offensive coordinator in
mike lafleur when everybody was getting
themselves excited about zach wilson
rising into the first round
many months ago left go everyone sat
there and even he said it himself on an
interview
the fit in a kyle shanahan offense is
perfect
his ability to throw on the run cut the
field in half
throw it all three levels with touch and
accuracy
well the jets offensive coordinator mike
leflore was kyle shanahan's passing game
coordinator for many years where
they're going to run the same principles
that wide zone running game
and all the things in the passing game
that i just told you about so if they
can move
make a move maybe sign a receiver draft
one
solidify that offensive line a little
more so it's not just makai bechten
it's a good fit for him listen when
you're a quarterback drafted in the top
three
are you ever going to this great landing
spot the answer is always no but you can
see the building blocks in place by joe
douglas
and the right offensive scheme for him
that it's
you know maybe not a match made in
heaven but a very very good one for the
number two overall pick
only one that sticks out to me is when
peyton manning hurt his neck
and then andrew luck got to go to a
colts team that was a lot better than
that first pick indicated they
were uh the other two quarterbacks you
have up there justin fields and trey
lance
i want to talk about fields first
because i was under the impression
when i saw him uh win against clemson
i was like oh we're not going to debate
this anymore
he's definitely one of the top guys i
feel like those debates are back so what
is a good
honest way to look at justin field so
that i'm not
only thinking about the clemson game and
i'm not only reading
people that are just hating on them all
the time well the people that don't like
fields will point you to the
northwestern game and the people that do
like fields will point you to the
clemson game and
quite frankly the type of player he is
is probably somewhere in between that
and he is a great one when you look at
the big board as a whole you saw
lawrence at one
but then it goes wilson three fields for
trey lance five
overall that means these guys are
special quarterback prospects
what i love about fields is the arm
strength is really good the deep
throwing especially when they had a
lobby on the field
was as good as anyone's i mean he can
really push the ball
down the field there's no throw on the
field that he thinks he can't make
and when you talk about as a real runner
not as a hey
i need to scramble i need to buy more
time and i'll take what's there
no justin fields will run and lower his
shoulder against a linebacker or he'll
try to make a defensive back miss to
pick up
not seven yards but 10 15 20.
and it goes back to that conversation
with trevor lawrence a great leader
since the day he transferred to ohio
state
came in really owned that locker room or
got the respect of the locker room
won a lot of big games everybody's
knocked on justin fields as he holds the
ball long
a lot of college quarterbacks do that's
something that you have to coach out of
these young guys and all of them are
very young so
i think whoever ends up with justin
fields as long as they can develop in
the right way
would you say about any quarterback
he'll be a really good one
this is the part of the draft if we were
to assume that trevor lawrence and zach
wilson go one
two where i feel like a lot of craziness
can happen
miami we don't know what they're doing
whether it's tua or looking for another
quarterback
atlanta with matt ryan do they move on
or do they play another season with him
cincinnati we just got a report today
that joe burrows coming back and he
looks great
and with the eagles with jalen hurts who
knows if they really think he's the guy
in the future
do you see someone like justin fields
going to one of those teams or do you
see another team
maybe making a move to come up and try
and getting someone of his caliber
i think there'll be a team that's just
too aggressive to go get him and the one
that i like the best is the denver
broncos honestly coming up from that
number nine spot and
you know they're picking at nine and
then number forty maybe that's all it
takes to jump up a couple spots maybe
you go
up to number four and atlanta's good
enough with that because atlanta sits
there and goes
the guy we're gonna take it for probably
gonna still be there at nine with all
these quarterbacks coming off the board
so
i look at justin fields and go will he
be for everyone
probably not and most quarterbacks
aren't will he be for a lot of
quarterback needy teams like the
panthers like the broncos
yes and the reason i look at the broncos
is lefko what have you noticed on all of
this footage where is he throwing the
ball it's 20 plus
yeah what do they have cortland sutton
kj hamler
jerry judy's a guy that'll probably work
in the intermediate underneath range
but all three of those guys can win big
down the field
and when they don't this is what he can
do he could take off and run and make a
play and pick up extra yards so
i think we'll see somebody be aggressive
to go up and get them and i think the
broncos are the most seamless fit of
them all
uh let's go to carson wentz's alma mater
north dakota state where what do you
know another
big impressive physical quarterback with
a nice arm and is not afraid to lower
his shoulder
trey lance is there he is also since you
have him in your top five
in this weird run of maybe they draft
maybe they trade
where would you like to see trey lance
end up who could make a move
well i think honestly the best situation
for him and maybe it's a little too rich
to go up and make that move would be
someone like the 49ers where
you have jimmy g there maybe trey lance
doesn't need to play right away because
let's not forget he's coming out of a
year
of fcs ball 2019 fcs ball
and then didn't have a season he had one
showcase game so i think when you look
at trey lance
ideally you like him to sit at least a
couple games and get acclimated to the
nfl level but
he's got it all i mean there's a reason
i compared him to air mcnair steve
mcnair that kind of throwback
the big body the tough running the deep
ball
and a lot of arm strength right is the
accuracy perfect
right now no but can you see the ability
to throw on the run so i look at the
niners as one of those teams that
we know they can develop him we know
they can maximize those traits
how much will it cost to go up and get
him is the biggest question
mark and will people be patient with the
quarterback
that had one true year of fcs ball
they'll have to be
we're about to bring in andrew whitworth
before we get there though it's been a
very interesting season
off season with quarterback movement
matt stafford goes to the rams which
we'll be talking whitworth about in
about a second the excitement there
i think a lot of it was spurned by tom
brady and what happened with tampa bay
are there any other teams that you're
hearing about maybe paying more
attention to the draft
and possible quarterbacks and
maybe we had already thought their
quarterback position was safe
well brace yourself because i think the
one right now
and it's a long shot but it's still
there is the seattle seahawks now the
question is
we saw those list of teams that russell
wilson would consider going to
is that going to be high enough to get
one of these quarterbacks no you'd have
to find a way to go back up again and
let's not forget the new york
jets have their first round pick this
year and next year because of the jamal
adams trade but i think when you look at
it with seattle
there is clearly a stare down there from
both sides and we've heard it all from
the rust side
but i have heard from the team side that
internally
they are trying to figure out who to
send and they will be sending people
to these quarterback pro days because
you can only send
three so i think what we're going to
keep an eye on lefko
will pete carroll be going there will
new offensive coordinator shane waldron
be going there will john schneider be
going there that's what we need to keep
an eye on we know seattle has done their
homework on quarterbacks in the past and
we've heard these rush trade rumors
forever
and because of the salary cap
ramifications it does seem like a long
shot this year
but it is clear for both sides that
i'm not so sure the long-term future
with russ and seattle
exists and it is interesting to me
internally that they have a scouting
department
that is essentially preparing like they
have to
treat they're going to be in position to
take one of these guys now
it's great to do your due diligence
they're a good front office it's
understandable that they're doing that
but it's still caught my eye a little
bit when i heard that
especially because seattle does not have
a first-round pick
that is owned by your new york jets that
was
acquired during the jamal adams trade
let us bring in a man that has played 15
nfl seasons
he was a big time pick for the
cincinnati bengals and was there for
about 11 years
and now just wrapped up his fourth year
with the l.a rams
the bayou legend andrew whitworth
andrew how are you sir good to see you
again what's going on man i'm doing good
uh i i need to ask we went back and we
saw some tweets that you wanted to go to
the senior bowl before
that you're interested in scouting i
know now that you've seen a lot of new
guys come into the room
draft season for you now that you've
seen like 15 of them after you've been
in the nfl
what are you actually looking for
amongst all this madness and rumors what
actually catches your attention
i think you're really looking for guys
that are more complete than flashy
i think that you look now in this league
if you want a rookie to play early
the flash plays look good but the real
consistency and the kids are going to
last 16 games
gonna be able to help a football team
actually get to the playoffs or possibly
make it
you know make a run in the playoffs
they're gonna be kids that play with
consistency and
i think last year you look at some of
those tackles and the guys that were
coming out you had a lot of really
special talented guys with flash to them
and
a guy like tristan wurst it's like
people were up and down a little bit on
you know it's like i want this guy
because of all his statistics of jumps
and running and all this to just explode
on the screen
but really it was just he was just that
strong and that good and then he gets in
the nfl it looks the same
way it's like man this kid's playing
football smoking cigarettes i mean
it looks like it's just easy to him and
that's that's the way he played the game
and the way he showed as a rookie to be
a heck of a football player
i love that andrew one guy that i know
that you've been
what were you gonna say go ahead let's
go i'm just curious andrew's an lsu guy
i gotta know is jamar chase the best
wide receiver in this draft i think he
is i just want to know what you think
i'll tell you this i i usually for me
it's like i don't watch a ton of college
sports all the time obviously i'll catch
my tigers and and
alabama just having played for nick i
watch a lot of his football
but it's one of those things to me i
remember turning on the tape of him
and and just really like i turn on a
game and i just catch flashes like who's
this receiver running
you know this route up here in the top
of the screen and then all of a sudden
they start throwing the football and you
see him
the way he catches it so easy how big
his hands are just at the catch point
it's like you go man all right i don't
know who this is i don't know if it's
just a really good college football
player
but uh this guy's got potential and then
you start kind of really diving into
seeing some of the things he was able to
do
i mean i i don't know who can be better
because he looks like a guy to me that's
like a really fast anquan boldins who i
think of like
when i think of like how smooth and just
tough making hard catches
but then also has speed and the ability
to do something with the football
connor fast and quan boldin is great who
was your who was the guy that you
compared him to in your analysis
i thought he looked like deandre hopkins
but i i'm with you know andrew here that
he's got juice right and you see it
after the catch too he's running by guys
that are starting in the nfl last year
and that's what jumps out to you right
away for somebody that was 19
when he was doing that so if you're a
fast anquan bolden or a deandre hopkins
i think you're going to be pretty good
and teams really quick before i go back
to andrew connor where do you think uh
jamar you'd like to see him land
well he brought up alabama he might be
playing with tua in miami i think that
one makes a lot of sense
uh you know he might be reunited with
joe burrow in cincinnati i think that's
a perfect fit for him you know aj green
era might be coming to an end
they need a number one help out joe
burrow when he's healthy and reuniting
with jamar chase
all right whitworth back to you penny
sewell
what have you seen out of this kid he's
the one offensive lineman that i'm
seeing as a top five guy
what has what have your veteran eyes
seen
well i think when you look at him
obviously the flash is there with him
for sure and
and i think that it's that size that
ability to move
and be that big those are things that
you don't find very often
it's like when you get stopped by people
they're like hey what does my son need
to be able to do to play in the nfl well
you know what if you had all the traits
penny sewell has uh there's the best
answer i can give you
uh this guy's got the ability to move
he's big he's strong he's got long arms
i think he's uh you know a really young
football player he's only 20 years old i
believe
so i mean you look there the development
that's still to come you look at like
rashawn slater and how good he looks
i mean he's three years older than him
so you know really there's a lot of
upside still left for sewell and i think
that's why you see him as a top five
pick because it's as good and talented
as he is right now
you know he hasn't even grown up and
really started to hit that man stride
where it's going to be like all right
where's the grown man strength going to
come into this with all that athleticism
you know what's the true upside of a
young player like that i think of tyron
smith when he came out
you know as far as looked like a great
athlete looked like he had long arms
good play but then as he got stronger
and older
man what a special football player he
became the body really changes
connor ice miami at three i don't know
if atlanta
cincinnati for sure at five where do you
see as a good spot for penny to go in
this
draft yeah it goes back to cincinnati i
know we love talking i just did it with
jamar chase and joe burrow but we saw
what happened when you don't protect
protect your quarterback last year and
this is someone that i'd you know i'd be
curious to ask andrew what a year off
would be like playing offensive line but
i think he can come in
and be lights out right away the way he
moves is like a tight end he explodes
out of his stance
the pulling is very very special really
clean and pass protection
i'm excited to see where he ends up and
he's got to help one of these young
quarterbacks maybe even the eagles there
it sits
i wouldn't even be surprised to see a
surprise team played up to get
because sure it's a good offensive line
draft i was glad you brought up rashawn
slater
but penne sewell is a special one yeah
eagles are interesting they don't really
know what they have in andre dillard
they're going to let go of jason peters
and lane johnson he was a little bit
banged up so the depth with
jordan maya lotta is a bit questionable
uh whitworth you brought up slater
it is pro day on tuesday um
who does this kid remind you of what
comes right to mind because i've enjoyed
your comparison so far
you know i don't know if i've pegged him
on somebody yet i mean you know watching
a little tape on him it reminded me a
little bit of watching tristan worse
last year just in the sense of it's not
like you see a lot of
extravagant movement out of him but he's
just really solid and strong and
athletic and
you know i i i i don't want to jump out
there ahead of myself i think peninsula
is going to be a tremendous football
player
i'm not entirely sure this kid's not
really ready to play
right this minute though i think
sewell's got some still polishing to do
with all his athleticism
and being really young and only having
limited football experience at that age
but i think that this kid man he he
really he fits the strength
you know all those metrics speed
watching that pro day was impressive um
and then you watch his tape man he just
seems to do it really simple and it
seems like hey i don't need a whole lot
of movement my head's not
all over the place my body's not all
over my plate all over the place because
when you get in the nfl you're gonna
face a guy like aaron donald a guy like
chandler jones a guy like nick
bose joey boses these guys they're going
to learn to use all that balance and all
that
athleticism against you and you better
be steady and solid and i think that's
something you see this kid his head
doesn't move all over the place his
center of gravity is under control
i think he's one of those guys that
could literally plug and play and play
well
immediately conor uh we saw him playing
right tackle there i know he's played on
both sides of the line because he has
played for three years
is this a guy that you think can sneak
into the top ten
oh absolutely i think i'd be more
surprised if he wasn't a top 10 pick
when you look at him
i thought it was even ridiculous there
were rumors about or questioning about
arm length if he'd have to play guard
sure he'd be a great guard because you
see the way he can cut off angles and
how well he moves
to the second level with reach blocks
but he was a
really good right tackle for two years
then a really good left tackle for a
year and you could watch the tape
against chase young and find that
evidence
i think slater comes in and like andrew
said pro ready i know he didn't play
this year but he's been working out like
an absolute maniac
he'll be good to go and you gotta love
that versatility even if people think
it's all pro guard level but you know he
has experience at right and left tackle
that only enhances his stock going into
this draft
so whitworth i made a lot of money last
draft because
the one thing connor well connor's good
at a lot of things but he's really good
at
seeing where like the fanduel draftkings
odds are wrong about the draft
do you have one about offensive lineman
conor for this year's draft that you
liked put a little bit of money on
well andrew kind of stole my shine a
little bit i put some money on rashaan
slater being the first offensive lineman
drafted and
i love penne sewell and i think that
listen he's the complete package but
we're coming into a year where you're
seeing all these cuts
you're seeing a super bowl team like the
chiefs are gonna need two new starters
at offensive tackle there's gonna be
plenty of teams that need
day one plug and play i either need you
on the left side or the right side
he checks every box lefko there are
teams that will probably look at rashaan
slater and say listen
i feel better about his polish right now
he's gonna start for us at day one
and he can play in any scheme
could you see conor could you see a team
like cincinnati
saying you know what we have jonah but
would we want to draft a kid like this
who could possibly play
left guard beside jonah for a year and
give us a chance to see whether
we think that jonah's going to make it
at that position or this kid could
eventually be
our left tackle or right tackle going
forward
that's exactly it right you look at it
because you have the jets at two and
even if they did hang on to sam darnold
we know mackay bechten
is going to be the guy going forward
with the bengals
i think it's a little bit more erratic
right now jonah
he's a good player there's no doubt
about that but if you take slater
you know you can play him at left guard
then you feel good about the left side
of your offensive line especially
in the run game especially with what
they want to do on that side of the ball
with zach taylor calling the plays and
joe mixon their workhorse back there so
i think slater when you look at his
draft ceiling it probably
starts at five and that might catch some
people's attention
but i would not overlook that draft slot
for him
andrew i gotta talk to you about
quarterback uh matt stafford who i'm
sure that you faced many times over your
career is now your quarterback
uh this is not something where it's hey
are do you like it more than jared
nothing like that
i'm curious uh what was your reaction
uh when you learned that stafford was
the guy and i really want to know your
level of respect for the guy because i
know that nfl players
think about matt stafford a lot
differently than fans think about matt
stafford
yeah i think for for all nfl guys i've
been around and know really matt's
career and what he's been able to do
i think you look at a guy that you think
of as just toughness and
a chip on his shoulder a little bit to
how he plays and competes
you know has not had the best run with
teams there in detroit and
talent around him i would say but a guy
that uh there's nobody in this league
that doesn't have a lot of respect for
that dude the way he competes
some of the throws he makes and really
the style of play he plays with at that
quarterback position
connor you got any questions for whit
before we let him go because he's
already
killed it and i think he's ready to be
the next draft analyst somewhere
i just want wit to join us next year
after he and all this i want him to come
back and we'll go through all the
offensive linemen we'll do this again
i know he's going to play until the end
of time he's going to outlast brady at
this point but i still want him to join
us for the draft
let's do it next year i'm in
awesome andrew whitworth thank you so
much everybody that's watching right now
twitter youtube the br app
shoot that man to follow andrew mann
thank you for your time dude
i appreciate y'all man have a great one
thanks andrew
all right uh we talked a little bit
about wide receivers he was really good
uh and i want i hope he hears that
because that was really good um
it was awesome we have an app what we're
gonna say connor
it was just awesome it's i always like
lefko
you know an exercise i've done with
offensive line prospects
recently like the last two years because
you know you actually start making some
connections is
go over the draft class with guys that
have at least
played offensive line at least the
college or nfl level or coaching
at the nfl level you'll hear a
perspective
that will blow your mind there's just
different nuances
at that position and i thought it was
interesting he had a really
he hinted at it right away that slater
might be a little bit more pro ready
than sewell
even though sewell has some special
traits that catch our attention all the
time
yeah and i think what what he said about
tristan wurst was a great point what i
would also say that in the same draft we
saw makai bechten
who was a little bit more of a
quote-unquote project that was a
physical specimen
that was equally as impressive so we got
a taste of both last year
i think last year's offensive line crop
will end up going as one of the best
we've seen in quite a long time
uh let's go i got one app comment here
it is who should be the first wide
receiver drafted this is from p
hall 27. uh who did you have as your
first was it jamar chase right
it is jamar chase i think when you look
at what he did as a 19 year old
at the highest level of college football
and like i said you can turn on the film
and see him running by guys or mossing
guys that are starting in the nfl right
now
special stuff special player should be
wide receiver one
okay but i know that you have a man
crush on number two and we're gonna get
to devonta smith and how he's not up
there you have rashad bateman at number
four terrace mitchell
marshall excuse me at number five how
would you compare jamar chase and jalen
waddle
completely different and i think in
great ways where
if jalen waddle didn't have a serious
injury this year
he would have made it an interesting
conversation if he was going to be the
first
guy off the board because he could fly
lefko we're talking about
speed in the four twos or on field speed
that was
special stuff in pads catch and run
phenomenal and
i know when i posted the comparison and
vr good arm post the comparison to tyree
kill
a lot of the reaction was and i
understand this they're like we get a
tyre kill each year
but nobody's tired kill this is the
closest it's going to be
this is somebody that is going to run in
the 4-2s on the field
in pads with acceleration after the
catch that
he's faster than everyone else and you
see two guys running behind him they
can't stay with him underneath the field
get up and go i think when you and he
was a phenomenal kick returner
screens he's always open jamar chase is
somebody that
he's a little bit of hey he's covered
but we know he's open we're going to
throw it up to him
with waddle there's times where if you
punch in just a little bit
you can't find any other defender on the
field they're falling down they're
grabbing their ankles so
i look at it if you need a deep threat
if you need more speed in your offense
you're considering taking waddle first
if you need somebody that is just going
to be stronger than everyone else they
face
and even after the catch as well you're
gonna go with chase
my super hot take here i don't think you
can go wrong with either
i think both will be two of the best
receivers in football two years from now
we have seen teams like uh
the chiefs take mccall hardman and we go
oh it's a great fit
we have seen teams like the raiders take
henry ruggs and go
oh they don't even know how to use this
guy so where would you like to see
someone of
waddle's profile go to maximize that
speed
oh it's a tough one right because you
want to go somewhere that they're going
to throw the ball down the field so
let's pull up our draft order here i
think when you look at it
you know the chargers at 13 would excite
me
we saw what justin herbert did last year
and i will gladly take the l on justin
herbert he blew expectations out of the
water
and sure they're a team that has drafted
plenty of wide receivers over the years
but you're looking at a really good
vertical passer
obviously somebody that can win down the
field you put him across from keenan
allen
my goodness lefko it would be electric
the problem is
i don't think he makes it there if
you're the new york giants at 11
you cannot pass on jaylen waddle unless
kyle pitts is somehow there and
you value that more for daniel jones so
he's a special player and he you know
like you said you want to see him go
somewhere that they're going to throw
the ball down the field
fortunately in his draft range i think
he's going to be okay
let us talk about the heisman trophy
winner
devonte smith who i am already
predicting
this is going to be the heated debate
for the next two months it will be the
discussion for years to go
because it's the age-old productivity
versus measurables and so why would you
say in your mind that you have devante
smith
behind them you still have them as a top
10 prospect but behind those other two
right he's great he's well-rounded he
catches everything
his tracking is better than the other
two
but he's not stronger than jamar chase
and he's not faster than jalen waddle
and i'm not just talking about putting
these guys on a track and saying
hey you know go run the 40. i'm i mean
you say right there let go
dbs can stay in stride with devonta
smith but his tracking of the ball and
high pointing of the ball is so good
that it often doesn't matter
so he's a really good athlete and sure
he's going to weigh around 175 we don't
see a lot of guys play
at that weight i know he's gotten marvin
harrison comparisons i see him more as a
why i was just kind of a player yeah
he's more santana moss to me who was
very very good let's not forget
but quite frankly he he's not he's a
good athlete
not an elite athlete on an nfl field
he's a strong player for his size he's
not elite strength
but he's so crafty he has a great
demeanor
that he'll find ways to win no matter
what
i don't think he lasts this long but 21
to the colts would be pretty special
just with all the marvin harrison
comparisons there are
i mean we didn't think cd lamb would
make it out of the top 15 last year so
never say never and if the cults have to
go up a couple spots
i'd like that one uh do you have any
draft prop
bets for this we already have one for
offensive linemen what about wide
receivers
last year you nailed it and said henry
ruggs could go first what about this
year
yeah you know this is a little bit of a
wild card a little bit of a long shot
and i've seen the
odds at plus 700 and even way higher
than that
why not throw some money on jalen waddle
being the top wide receiver being taken
are we ever surprised anymore let go
when one of the fastest guys
ends up being the first this goes back
to darius hayward bay it doesn't
nothing ever surprises you anymore when
speed is taken it just doesn't anymore
you have
all these old school nfl scouts that are
you know
looking at players that didn't play this
year and making up ridiculous quotes
along the lines of that does that happen
at jamar chase
it shouldn't i don't think it will but
when those odds are that ridiculous
that's one that's fun to me one that
people are sleeping on and it might be
off the books at some point because i
think it's so ridiculous
i saw mac jones over under pick 17 and a
half
smash the under on that mac jones should
be a top 15 pick
and that just smelled like free draft
money to me i was so excited lefko that
i texted you
literally as soon as i placed my bet you
did
and i hit up my guy and he said they're
not available at my book yet and i went
ah
crap so i'm hoping that it's still there
uh when they eventually pop
up we're about to do some rapid fire q a
in the br
app uh as you can see i'm i'm rating
there
so get in there and comment there we do
have one from our own
buddy matt densed it phil in the black
micah is the best linebacker prospect
since
and then he added kiekley there i guess
his own answer
uh connor you know is is micah parsons
that wild
and who does he remind you or best
prospect since
oh best prox prospects since at
linebacker since roquan smith
that went to the bears who really turned
it on this year he had a
quietly a nominal season and my player
comp
if you looked at br gridiron was luke
lee
so you look at it it's just it's a layup
it's such a
you know i don't always feel great about
comparisons for saying this is who he'll
be
but this kind of athleticism and range
and reading your keys
and getting down field to make a tackle
he's a 4-5 runner
he's got great size he's a good blitzer
the coverage instincts are they perfect
yet or up to lou keegley standards
no but he's such a young player that
those will develop with his athleticism
he could run with any linebacker and
tight end so
uh i would pay a lot of money to just
watch him and kyle pitts do one-on-ones
for an entire afternoon
uh drafting a defensive player
in the top ten where your other nine
guys are all offense is tough
uh i'm just kind of looking around who
do you think could pull the trigger it
is interesting you have carolina there
at eight
and we got these luke keikley
comparisons uh
what is there a team that kind of caught
your attention for this penn state
linebacker
uh yeah i think you go with detroit at
seven you know they traded for jared
goff we're gonna see how that goes
uh maybe they're trade back if a team
comes up for one of those quarterbacks
that fall
i don't think detroit is in this big
hurry to take a quarterback and and
develop him or get him on the field i
think they'll ride it
out with jared goff right now and they
need to get better on the defensive side
of the ball
and they need to get more athletic on
both sides of the ball
and this solves those things right away
and if you watch any of those campbell
press conferences left go
i think it's pretty obvious the kinds of
players he likes these smash
mouth kind of guys that come out of the
big ten
i think micah parsons is a really really
good fit there in detroit
if not there he might slide out of the
top 10 a little bit you know do the
giants do enough in free agency that
they go hey
we got our skill guys in free agency we
could take a linebacker at 11.
we know dave gettleman has no problem
doing that
onya uh said oh so he's like jared davis
that was my other thing too is
the detroit has had some issues draft
ernie sims
i was a linebacker they took early on in
that draft too
uh the panthers i just i think about
that defense with jeremy chin and
they they went last year and drafted all
of their players on defense the the
offense has experienced their defenses
all defense but
or it's all young guys but they they
need a lot of help everywhere
worst kept secret though left go with
the panthers they are
dying for a quarterback and if they
can't get to sean watson
i think they'll they'll use the same
leverage use whatever capital they have
to be aggressive
maybe they sit at eight but maybe
there's a guy they like so much that
they move up to six with your eagles
four to the falcons i think the panthers
are going to be all
over getting a franchise guy yeah
i think also as as we look around what
team needs are
let's wait until after next week we are
about to see the franchise
tags go official that's kind of been
settled and then free agency will open
next week
and and that's this is the difference
between this and the nba
is that we are going to have the free
agency and then the draft and we'll see
how that develops let's go to now some
rapid
fire q a as we wrap up the nfl draft
crash course here
uh black fin asking travis etienne of
clemson or naji harris
out of alabama who i covered in high
school which is crazy
conor who's your rv pick there it's
going to be naji harris and it was not
easy lefko
these guys to me both graded out as top
30 players
and it's going to come down to what do
you want for your offense etn is a home
run hitter with great speed i saw it as
pro day he got up to 215 pounds
and still ran a 4-4 but let's talk about
naji harris who
at six foot two 230 pounds is still
running away from defenders in the sec
and there you go the circle button b
button whatever you want to use
the full package of moves at the second
level of the field the spin move the
stiff arm the cut
the hurdle he's got it all he reminds me
of steven jackson left go look at that
little shoulder at the end that says i
don't care that we're going out of
bounds
you're going to feel this contact naji
harris
is a special player he's built for 30
touches from day one
he can pass protect he can catch the
ball like a receiver that's why you see
a lot of those matt forte
comparisons as well it's these are
really good running backs at the top of
this drive you can hear how excited i
get when we talk about the skill guys
so naji i know we're doing rapid fire oh
okay we'll go on give me one team for
naji just give me one
uh naji harris let's go with
poof uh the steelers i guess
okay i was also looking at arizona at
16. it might be a little bit too early
okay this one from trap trap z dizzle
which top prospect has the most red
flags that teams should avoid look
deeper into
and this is big for a draft year in
which we don't have a lot of information
so i'll give you one that i don't want
to raise like the character concerns or
anything like that but i'll tell you
that teams are doing an immense amount
of homework on
right now because he is so talented is
jalen phillips the pass rusher from
miami
there was a time in the recruiting
process when he was going to ucla
this guy was the next miles garrett and
it got so bad with injuries
that he had to medically retire from
football at one point
he doesn't play the year he transfers to
miami
then he gets on the field in 2020 under
manny diaz
and he lights the world on fire a great
run defender
can bend at six foot five 260. i mean
special stuff in this edge group teams
are trying to figure out
one is he okay medically to continue on
or can we rely on him
and two you know how much does football
mean to him i know it sounds stupid but
these are questions that
scouts get paid to look into so i would
say he's the most important one because
if those things check out he's a top 20
pick
and as you were telling me before it is
not a big deep class of pass rushers
and also it's very interesting is it's a
great crop of pass rushers in free
agency so we'll see what happens there
next one
jay underscore my should the jets keep
darnold
or draft zach wilson this is right down
your alley connor
um well i think they should draft zach
wilson and trade sam darnold and i think
they
will draft zach wilson and trade sam
darnold so i think you're looking at it
uh all the buzz is that sam darnold is
going to bring back at least a second
round pick maybe you get
some some change with that a two and a
four a two and a conditional three
something along the lines of that
and every bit of rumblings i have heard
is that the jets are really
zeroing in on zack wilson at two
if they find the right trade package
with sam darnold
niners who are you thinking
uh niners bears washington football team
those are the three um
they got heineken why would they do that
okay uh we're gonna get
one more rapid fire q a shout out to
everybody on the br
app the youtube page and of course be
our good iron twitter herschel
underscore welkner
who's gonna bring the funk the thump the
old school nitty gritty my guess is that
kid from app state
what do y'all think connor funk thump
nitty gritty oh the nitty gritty is the
part that got
that has me kind of tied up here we'll
keep it with the blue chippers here and
i'll still say micah parsons i'm telling
you right now
you just don't see a lot of linebackers
who's the app state guy that he's
talking about sorry for interrupting you
school me on whoever he's saying let's
take a look in the doc because i don't
even know who he's thinking of with
the thunder trying to bump this up i i
think he is and actually i really like
that well
first one in app state i still have
jalen virgil in the dock the wide
receiver
i don't know it's we'll figure it out at
some point let's go we're probably
looking at day three players at that
point
okay so mike i love when the rapid fire
the rapid fire throws me off i
appreciate that from our uh
from our pal herschel walker there i
like that too
um okay shout out to everybody in the
app
that's been commenting it's been a lot
of fun uh do you have
do you have an ultimate man crush in
this draft uh is it jaylen waddle or is
it somebody else
i'm gonna go with jaylen waddle i think
but the name you're gonna hear me throw
around as the the day three non-stop day
crush would be jalen darden another
speed wide receiver
out of north texas so we'll keep it with
the wide receivers in this one
i cannot wait until we do our version of
who he play for
where you name prospects that are not
real and i just fall for them
hook line and sinker darden i i got you
uh we are gonna be doing this guys
every thursday at 1 pm eastern
uh right here in the br app gridiron
twitter and the br youtube
we did blue chip prospects this week
next week is going to be
most electric players this is going to
be the fast guys the speed guys the guys
that can jump over people
the guys that kind of like leviska
chanel last year we get excited about
going up to the season because what
happens
if he is everything he's cracked out to
be uh and as you see there on the bottom
of the screen
send videos in the nfl draft community
in the br app that's your chance to win
swag from hoodies to everything else
that we have
and we might be playing your comment
so make sure you do that uh and for all
the guys listening on the
left go show podcast we love it connor
any final note before we get out of here
it was a blast we've been so excited to
kick this off uh
our guy andrew whitworth was phenomenal
and we're gonna have guests all the time
so if you really enjoyed that portion of
it that's great if you want to listen
to the show you can listen to it on the
left go show stream
if you want to re-watch the show you can
go to the bleacher report app
or youtube or you know i think a lot of
people like to re-watch on youtube so
there it is we're going to be doing this
every week until the draft clef go
awesome uh you're right whitworth killed
it for connor rogers for whitworth
for all of the people at bleacher report
and turner that have me broadcasting out
of a briefcase
and have somehow figured out a way to do
this god bless you
brett canvas or everybody that helped
put this thing on we're excited to do it
so everybody out there in the vr
community
have an awesome day and enjoy as we get
ready for the nfl draft see you guys
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you